hello reject nation
I'm Greg what's your name white girl
this is Lisa mihalick she has a YouTube
channel now she actually about a little
over a year ago filmed a movie called
ice the movie about ice cubes in your
freezer ice skating movie Lisa put a lot
of hard work into it and it will be
available on Amazon soon right now the
filmmakers have put it out on Vimeo you
can get it over there we'll put a link
in the description box for you guys one
day I'll watch it with Lisa mm-hmm I'm
gonna judge the movie partially Lisa I
have a channel you have a channel now
you know who else has a channel William
Smith and that's crazy he's he's clean a
good kind of wet and we watched his
channel trailer I've actually never seen
any of his videos but his channels
blowing up oh really
yeah apparently it's really easy when
you're Will Smith and you're already
having his secrets you see where are my
subscribers gotta do we got amigo
millions and millions of dollars you do
crazy vlog he already had a million
subscribers and he has this little vlog
video of called celebrating 1 million
subscribers at Jimmy Fallon's oh wow so
let's check this out Lisa headphones on
Lisa
headphones are locked and loaded alright
let's do
[Music]
[Applause]
Will Smith and his selfie stick love it
way to go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
New York
[Music]
backstage sorry can pause I should
probably check it should I check it to
make any change
Wow around his waist - this would be
good for a horror movie this would be
good for our movie I just thought about
that right so you put some horror music
[Laughter]
so we will try to get that repaired you
can't afford that
no just like the plain issue this is so
cool
this really is it's like a famous person
doing his own behind the scenes yeah
yeah we have YouTube channels can we go
to Jimmy Fallon
I gotta watch this actual interview Wow
the trippy shot I'm like in all of this
right now the fact he can do this live
us life like this it's his own show
sorry Jimmy that's standing of it as a
small studio you put that on okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
the world is watching you know just
really gives me the opportunity
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
now Jimmy sent to it let's get these
shots his lucky ass audience natural my
god it looks so weird
that's what life has come to 1 million
subscriber blacker
[Music]
better than any so where's her speech
this is one of the most fascinating
things I've ever seen a famous person
like already mega superstar do who's
really uploading a lot cuz when this
video was recommended to us and then I
went to his channel Oh Will Smith does
like he has been uploading in the past
three months he's becoming like an
actual youtuber what are you interesting
way for him to stay relevant and it's
not like he's just doing nothing like
he's going on in adventures and stuff
he's interacting with the audience he's
going back to the Will Smith that we all
first fell in love like way back when
and he's showing he's just another human
being like everyone else I mean he's not
just a regular human behavior he's going
back to that relatability you know and
just that really funny ass Will Smith
that we loved yeah I feel like this has
to be so mind clearing for him know what
I mean because he has such a big name
he's done so many things and this is
just him alive
his excitement I felt was genuine here
it was his life he was like yes it's
finally I'm not being interviewed for a
movie well I think it's because of the
love that he's getting from just his
fans like it's the love from his fans
it's crowding him this attention do you
seem genuinely happy about getting the 1
million placard and the cool thing is is
he's Will Smith so we ain't doing this
for money
no like whatever a few thousand dollars
he gets out of this is like nothing to
what will smith money is you know yeah
this is just for fun and he's doing this
like the people and this I'm sure in
some ways this is gonna help out his
career in terms of just staying really
relevant he's someone that's already so
likable and this just like time said I
missed the show Fresh Prince I feel like
he was so likable there and like he said
like some really deep dramatic movies
and yeah he's a very comedic person but
this kind of brings that back for us
that brings it back to life this is who
Will Smith is yeah and at this point in
his career I'm like yeah let's get back
to like who's Will Smith you know but
he's already been a successful rapper
he's a successful actress successful
producer successful such a massive
following outside of this all he has to
do is keep telling people he has a
channel and it'll just keep girl he
doesn't need to do much he also has the
coolest vlogs based off the channel
trailer because he has so much money to
like and it's a private plane to and
doing that on The Tonight Show was like
a cool little behind-the-scenes that we
got it's like that I watched Jimmy all
the time I think he's so funny he's one
of my favorite hosts I've never seen his
studio like that though that is cool
like thanks well you know you get a
taste of what it's like for a guest to
be there yeah Jimmy was so thrown off
that was hysterical it's like you have
to he has to know what wills gonna be
talking about but he still seemed like
so like wait what well it's so far for
routine when you get such a guy on that
status walks out you
well Will Smith I'm subscribing well
thank you Will Smith for being such a
great youtuber you guys can subscribe
you the Will Smith channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell
Lisa mihalick has her own YouTube
channel as well lifestyle and whatnot go
check it out one day I'll be on it
teaching her how to really have curly
hair and that's about as far as I can go
and I don't have good advice because
this changes daily depending on the
weather and check us out on patreon a
lot of good perks over there I would
love to have you